sand miners dive under the waves again
and again filling their nets with heavy
shell sand what they're doing is illegal
but building contractors pay a high
price for the sand
the miners earn nearly 10 euros a day
because of the mining the sea is
steadily encroaching on the land the
beach beside Togo's capital low May is
gradually disappearing I fix Otto and
his friends pray every morning for the
sand mining to stop
they also pray for a good harvest just a
stone's throw from the beach he and his
family have a fruit and vegetable garden
his garden is planted in the sand and
produces enough to feed the family when
it's hot the garden needs to be watered
several times a day you can harvest the
vegetables after a few weeks we pull out
the weeds and put down fresh dung and a
month later we get more vegetables we
repeat this four to five times a season
everything depends on the condition of
the soil but the garden is that risk of
being washed away by the sea Kimiko CUDA
heads an initiative called permaculture
Togo everything he and his colleagues
have planted on the beach has grown in
the last year they want to show how part
of the beach can be turned into a fruit
and vegetable garden
permaculture means building up a
sustainable form of organic farming that
relies solely on renewable resources
that nature itself provides a single
coconut palm can't hold back the sea but
if you plant many palms together like
here then the roots soon interlink they
pull together if you like and then they
have more of a chance against the waves
but for that to work the ground has to
retain its moisture natural materials
like shrub
animal dung and wood shavings are added
to the sand which allow it to retain
water and keep the plants strong and
healthy in five years time the coconut
and banana trees will be large enough to
stop the sand from washing away and will
also feed more families the sand mining
and the bigger waves are a huge problem
along Togo's coastline environmental
activists Fabrice OB from lo Mei has
spent the last 15 years observing the
disappearance of the land cemeteries are
being washed away houses too and
biodiversity is suffering trees and many
other kinds of plants are disappearing
even farmland there's a lot of marshland
that is farmed along the coast
everything that's by the water is
gradually being washed away year after
year and residents are left in this
vicious circle of poverty in renko
boobies garden the bananas are ripe for
harvest everything here is planted in
sand
many of togo's coastal residents could
have Gardens like hers if they plant at
the beach according to the principles of
permaculture she runs a dried fruit and
herbs business several times a week
she'd rise have fresh mangoes and
pineapples in the Sun
Nissan wasa IBM above wah this is where
I dry my fruit and herbs I try to keep
everything as clean as possible people
like that of course I have to fetch them
out at the right time otherwise they go
hard and then I can't sell them ramier
been kibou Vee has gradually expanded
her garden a packet of chilies costs
about two euros while lemongrass costs
one conservationist Fabrice abhi talks
regularly to the residents in these
coastal areas he says if local people
and the government of Togo don't act
fast this strip of coastal land will be
swallowed up by the sea within 20 years